-Hey, everybody.
This is so exciting.
Our next guest is an Emmy
winner, a Golden Globe winner.
You know her
from "Parks and Rec."
She used to carry me on her back
at "Weekend Update"
on "Saturday Night Live."
It's our very good friend
Amy Poehler, everybody.
-Hi, everybody.
Hey, Seth.
-Hi!
How are you?
-I'm -- I'm great.
You know, pretty bored.
Nothing new going on.
The world is just --
-Well, I heard, though,
you did have
a really interesting project
you wanted to share with u
that's happening outside -
right outside your window.
-Yeah.
You know, now it doesn't fee
like the time to promote
anything that people
are working on.
But I do have one project
that I'm really excited
to talk to you guys about.
I mean, I produced it,
but I feel like
it was the birds that really
took it over the top.
-The birds.
-A bird's nest.
-Oh, there's a bird's nest
-Yeah.
And I sent you guys a picture.
-Oh, here we are.
We're looking at the photo now
and it is just beautiful.
-I mean,
you can't really tell --
you can't really see the birds
'cause they won't let me
get close to them.
Because they're very
temperamental artists.
-Yeah.
-But, yeah.
Hoping we sell it to Nestflix.
[ Both laugh ]
I'm going crazy!
Well, this is all the erotic
I've been writing
during quarantine.
These are all my --
-A book a day, right?
You're writing a book of erotica
a day.
-My libido's so high,
and I got to get it out.
So just a book a day.
And I made --
-Well, this is -- because this
is the future of intimacy,
we'll be reading erotica, right?
People are never gonna
touch each other ever again.
-Yeah. That's right.
You're just gonna be --
you're gonna sit
on a park bench,
and someone else will sit
and you'll read the erotic
that you wrote.
And you'll just stare at eac
other from like a mile away.
-It's gonna be like
17th-century romance
from now on for everybody.
Just, like, glances.
-Yeah, just, like, tiny --
Like, ankles
and face masks dropping.
-Have you seen
"A Portrait of a Lady on Fire"
Have you seen that movie yet
-I haven't yet.
I can't wait to see it.
-It's a lot of that.
It's a lot of, like, glances
-A lot of face masks.
[ Both laugh ]
-Like, there is, like,
just through, like, netting.
-You know that there's
definitely people out ther
right now that are like,
"This is my kink."
Like, "Hooray!"
-Oh, you mean like
someone's kink is never gettin
within 6 feet of anybody?
-Yeah, there's got to be
somebody that's like,
"I like to wash my hands and
like, not touch anybody
and wear face masks and gloves
and be scared."
I don't know.
-Right.
And do you think they're, like
having to pretend, like,
"Oh, this is such
a bummer for me."
But in the back of their head,
they're like, "Ai-yi-yi-yi-yi!
-"Finally."
Or maybe they're mad that al
the basic people are doing it.
-Yeah, that's true.
But I do --
Don't you feel bad for kid
who have to date?
Like, dating is not,
like, possible.
-Yes. I feel like
there's so much pressure.
Like, you know
how it used to be, you know,
"Will you go to the prom
with me?"
Like, that was the big ask
Now it's gonna be like, "Do yo
want to quarantine with me?"
-Yeah.
-"Will you spend two weeks
an uninterrupted two weeks
with me,
and watch me do my laundry?"
It's --
-Well, I do think that will lead
to maybe not as good
a relationship
but more honest relationships.
-Yeah, I mean, I will give
the credit to where it's due
which is Mike Scully,
the writer Mike Scully,
who writes on "Duncanville,"
a show that is on right no
if you want to watch.
He coined the term
quaran-tweened.
-Quaran-tweened -- I love it
-Which is -- I love it.
And that's what's happenin
to me right now.
I'm quaran-tweened.
So I have children who are
not quite young enough
to not, you know, be anxious
or need to learn schoolwor
but not quite old enough
to be able to do anything
for themselves.
Or, you know,
do any chores, really.
-Do you have any tips for
parents who are homeschooling?
Mine are too young, but it
doesn't matter what I do now
-Yeah, it doesn't matter.
It's great.
I don't know.
I find it fascinating
that we found yet another way to
shame working mothers right now.
And working fathers.
Don't get me wrong.
Both parents
are parenting right now.
But it is amazing that, like
on top of everything else,
I'm also supposed to be
working full-time
and also creating
all these exciting
educational adventures
for my kids.
And if I see one more
Instagram thing of, like,
someone being like,
"If you're thinking --
If you're needing
something to do today,"
or like, "If you're out of ideas
what to do" --
It's like,
"No, I have the ideas."
-[ Laughs ]
-I don't have the time.
I don't have the time
or the willingness
for my children to do the ideas.
-I don't even have
the construction paper
or the scissors or the tape.
And I don't wanna go out
and buy those things.
-You can't buy those things!
Those things are gone!
There's no more of those!
[ Both laugh ]
Can you imagine right now
if you were, like,
hustling and bustling to go ou
to buy construction paper?
Oh, man.
-Yeah, taking the risk.
Risking it all for that.
-Just, like, bumping into people
at the store being like,
"Excuse me!
Where's the construction paper?"
People would be like,
"Get out of here, lady."
-[ Laughs ]